ouais tu entendu ça c'est strange non
ouah c'est une mouche mais nous aussi
[ __ ] c'est une mouche et pour quoi on
sert pas de la mouche là pour se reposer
pour l'adresse comme un singe que l'on
voyait tu vois dans une banque pour nous
ramener le pognon de la banque et nous
on fait rien on apprivoise idlib
horizons et c'est fou de se voir c'est
quoi ce courant attendu comme le second
casse-toi je connais pas je sais pas qui
est ce une deux une qui me prend pour un
autre mec chez toi le truc hockey ou
quoi les arrêtés pour combien de temps
les crados la savoie avait préparé des
paupiettes de dad
elle a eu un choc au cerveau après un
accident de ski et depuis ben et parle
comme ça quoi bon appétit à tous laissez
vous dans cette jambe ont fermé comme ça
je peux rien je regarde pas mais
poitrine wii dont se revendre à traquer
crayola histoire dont c'est le monde qui
est détraqué equal les gens pètent les
plombs
wow ça craint alors c'était quoi ce gros
machin une mouche une mouche ouais
[Musique]